the next speaker
thank you very much to the organizers
for this great workshop and for inviting
me can you hear me okay yeah okay right
so I I was not expecting Matt's talk to
be this relevant to my my talk too so
it's great that hopefully you guys will
be able to see lots of links between
between our work over my work is going
to be a bit more on the experimental
side today but I'm going to try to show
you what we can learn about that in
terms of what computations the brain is
doing and maybe get some some new
intuitions for people building AI
systems so one of the things that Matt
talked about a bit is the fact that you
can have reinforcement learning dynamics
at multiple time scales so that's the
reinforcement learning that's happening
to train a network and then there's the
reinforcement learning behavior that
happens just as dynamics of the network
with the actual learning rate being
fixed to zero and so I think that's
highlights but the fact that
reinforcement learning means many
different things and that's something I
try to work with in my in my lab
focusing on white means in terms of
computation in terms of cognition and in
terms of neuroscience and I try to think
of those three things at the same time
and bind them together and of course
they're very related but there are also
very interesting differences as asthma
has already pointed out so I'll show you
the case of reinforcement learning today
so in computation we think of
reinforcement learning simply as a class
of reinforcement learning algorithms and
has already talked about this a lot so
I'm not going to expend too much and I
will only say that today I'm focusing
only on the one of the simplest cases
it's not even quite reinforcement
learning it's this Delta rule kind of
learning where you try to just update
expected values or estimated values
where the reward prediction error
in your science matter also talked about
this for a day so it's great I can skip
over it we know that there is this
dopaminergic system here that signals
essentially reward prediction errors so
it bursts when there's an expected
reward that is predicting by a stimulus
potentially here if the reward is
predicted here then there's no signaling
and if reward is expected but doesn't
appear it's reduce so this seems to be
exactly what we would want for a reward
prediction error system in the brain and
lots of work has been done to show that
essentially this cortex to stratum loops
that Matt told us about two are
implementing this kind of computations
thank so that's an example of where we
can use this thoughts about computation
to inform us about what is happening in
those circuits here on the brain from
cortex proposing stimuli and action
choices and stratum gating those choices
based on the values so so implementing
the policy analysis okay computation is
also super helpful for understanding for
capturing cognition and again matt has
given many examples of that but
essentially you can give an example here
of an animal choosing between two arms
of a bandit here two rodent and here the
green is good the orange is good it's a
tried switches and the little ticks here
is when the animal does not get reward
but the big ticks one when it does get
everyone so you see that the animal can
learn this very well and you see here
with the completion of the full line and
the dotted line that the mall captures
this behavior of the animal really
really well
okay so because it's so successful in a
sense the the field for a long time has
had the tendency to say well we have are
all in the eye and we have aryl behavior
and we have errol and neuroscience and
because they're working so successful
together we tend to want to you know say
it's one and the same thing and i think
as we've already seen an example
of today it's really not the case you
have to think about reinforcement
learning at multiple aspects and how
they inform each other and that's I'm
going to try to give you an example of
that today and in particular I'm going
to try to say that for human learning
you can certainly count on those
reinforcement learning algorithms to
capture some aspects of it but you also
need to think about other algorithm that
may be lying different sides of various
trade-offs to capture some aspects of
behavior and same you also need to think
about different neural circuits okay and
for example prefrontal cortex is one of
the ones that Matt talked about and that
I'm going to focus on today okay so
that's my goal is to say to capture
human learning you need to think about
more than a single algorithm
contributing jointly to to human
behavior and I'm going to focus on
working memory in addition to what is
classically thought of as reinforcement
learning and I'll try to show you why
it's really important to think of it in
as to think of learning as a mixture of
multiple algorithms by showing you how
it helps us explain learning these
functions in people with schizophrenia
and in the last part I'll talk about
whether we can actually think of those
systems as independent so Matt told us
that there were specific training the
the network and then he turned it off
and then we had prefrontal cortex just
doing all the work on its own in my case
I'm going to show you that actually you
really need to have both at the same
time and also that it's very likely that
they're not independent and that they
actually kind of mess up with each
other's computations in improbably
interesting and useful ways and yeah
okay so I'm assuming that most of you
don't think about working memory all the
time and so I'm going to just give a
quick example of what I mean here by
thinking of all those two systems so if
you think back to when you were
how to drive what is very likely to have
happen is that you I don't know read a
book about how to drive or someone gave
you instructions or something that and
you just try actively to to follow those
instructions guys first of all speed
limits indicating on your turn if you're
not from the US you might have been
super confused about four-way stops are
the fact that there's red lights but
that you're allowed to go anyway and
also you might have you know tried
actively to remember to look in your
right mirror so that you don't
accidentally kill a bicyclist okay so
and that's just five rules okay but
that's something that you might have
tried very hard to hold in your mind
while you were driving and inevitably
what happens when you're first learning
here is that you're going to forget to
pay attention to some of those so for
example you're going to forget to pay
attention to your speed or something
like that and then what happens is that
you're going to get a ticket and that's
negative reinforcement and that's going
to tell you to not spin next time okay
and so that's really highlighting the
fact that in any learning we really have
those two systems one more we're
actually trying to remember and use that
to make our choices and the other one
that's well you did something wrong do
better next time okay and so that's my
two the two algorithms I'm focusing on
today working memory and what alcohol
instrumental learning or enforcement
learning and they have very different
different kind of properties that seem
to be optimized for different kinds of
trade-offs of gathering and storing
information so working memory is known
to be something that's very fast you can
just learn something in one trial it
stores information precisely not just
accumulated value but exactly what
happened and it's very flexible you can
decide to start something and to forget
it
irelia study is incremental it's just
integrating the estimated value over
time
and it's inflexible in the sense that
I'm learning something from are all
takes time okay so those are pluses for
working memory the the other side of the
trade-off is that you actually can't
remember whose working memory as much as
you would like it so it's very
well-established writes you know
capacity or resource limit in some sense
so you can't there's only a fairly small
amount of information that you can store
in working memory it's also limited in
time from a few seconds to a few minutes
essentially and it's also effortful its
it requires attention or control in a
sense okay whereas RL is supposed to
have a very broad capacity to be long
term very robust that's the flip side of
it being flexible and to be effortless
so I'm going to try to show you now it
is a very simple simplistic kind of task
environments where we try to show
evidence for how those two systems work
together in behavior and then see how we
can capture that with computations and
and then move from there to look into
the brain and see whether those two
systems are independent okay so here's
the task if you're active in this task
you'll see something on the screen for
example Vesta Moss the pumpkin and then
you'll make a choice by pressing one of
three keys and then you'll get feedback
and our feedback is very simple it's
just if you press the correct key you
get correct 100% of the time and if you
didn't you get incorrect otherwise so no
noise no nothing complicated very
simplest thing you can think about and
then you've seen other stimulus for
example the green beans and you make a
choice again and you get feedback and
this repeats for awhile for example
approximately 15 times per for stimulus
okay and that's one learning block and
then you go on to a different learning
block where you see difference to me
okay the key manipulation is that in one
block you might just learn about those
two pick the correct to press the
correct key for those each of those two
stimuli and in other blocks you might
have three four five
six different steamer to one Bob so this
is for example block that I will call a
block of size six because you have to
learn six the most action associations
in this case so this manipulation lets
us get at what we're trying to do here
it has a reinforcement learning
component because we're we're giving
people feedback and so we can simply
test the effect of reward history on how
how well participants make choices and
the set size manipulation targets
working memory because and in two
separate boys one of them is simply that
in this case you have a just a higher
load if you're trying to use working
memory you're going to try to actively
remember sixty most action associations
which is a lot there's also you can also
test the temporal aspect of working
memory because in this block you'll see
every image every other trial verse in
this this block you'll see them every
six trials in average and so you can try
to see the effect of interferring
interleaving intervening stimuli
okay so if you take this task and just
take very simple reinforcement learning
agent and simulate this agent on this
task this is what you predict the
behavior would be so I'm planning
problem like belonging cars the product
key that the agent is correct as a
function of how many times its
encountered or given stimulus for
example the pumpkin you see that the
five curves here overlap perfectly and
that's because this reinforcement
learning agent is just learning
independently the value of actions for
each stimulus and so it does not care
that there are thus more than one thing
to learn so that's a turbo prediction
this is what humans do instead instead
humans when there's only two stimuli to
learn about they try one they try the
second action and then they try the
third action and by then they reach
asymptotes so that's optimal performance
in the case of testimony but you see
that as soon as the number of stimuli
to learn associations for increases the
performance gradually decreases okay so
we have an effect on set size that can't
be accounted for about any form of
classic reinforcement learning and it
also can't be accounted for by any
variance you might think about that I've
tried at least in the past the first
opal you could add simple forgetting in
your reinforcement learning algorithm
which would give you a little bit of
this set size effect just due to the
fact that stimuli are more more rarely
seen in inherited sizes but it clearly
does not capture qualitatively well the
shape of participants learning okay so
this shows us this in other noses shows
us that's really to capture the behavior
of humans we can't just stick with only
this algorithm we actually have to add
working memory there so we model working
memory in a very simplistic way I simply
assume lights a way to start very fast a
very limited amount of information so
I'm going to start in such a way that
essentially for example that's about 60
miles Association I'm going to put this
capacity limit here that says well I'm
I'm going to remember perfectly go 3 and
forget those three and this is probable
taking them all so based on the capacity
essentially if the number of stimuli to
remember is below capacity the row of
working memory is it's going to be
maximum but then it's going to decrease
inversely with a greater number of
steamer and all the equations are in the
papers okay and so now I'm assuming that
the behavior of humans is actually a
mixture of ass for humor model that's
parametric that's characterized by two
crucial parameters this capacity and
some decay of information working memory
and the reinforcement learning module
that's parameterize by the learning rate
okay and then we have a mixture way
that's capturing this this contribution
of working memory to
to behavior as a function of capacities
that so when you do that you you can fit
the participants that are with the model
and infer parameters that best capture
each individual participants behavior
and then you can simulate the data the
task with them all and you see that you
can recover much better participants
behavior okay
so that supports the fact that you have
yes can forget instantly I always think
of my own memory as a whiteboard with a
sharpie on it you can write on but you
can't erase it is this no actually this
is not a property of my model my mo
actually has a gradual decay in it I I
mean there is evidence that people can
just forget immediately it's probably
not what happens most of the time
well psychology teaches that
introspection is not always the best way
to figure out what's happening in the
brain but ok so we have those two
modules that we show essentially capture
behavior really well and we just wanted
to try to get some evidence very related
to the two separable neural systems so
to do this when we went into looking at
even individual differences between
participants trying to see how they
related to individual differences in yes
the working memory module makes a choice
[Music]
it's it's a greedy policy based on the
information that it remembers
okay so we looked at people have
individual differences in in some genes
that are related separately either to a
preform to our Australian function so we
targeted one of those genes that come to
you that has been repeatedly and and
yeah repeatedly related to the role of
prefrontal cortex in working memory and
we know about there's an allele that
captures individual differences there
and then we also targeted GPR six which
is a gene that's essentially expressed
on the in Australia and that's very
important for plasticity in this right
so we said well essentially if there are
individual differences in behavior that
can be captured by either of those two
behavioral systems when they should
relate to individual differences in the
expression of specific alleles and these
genes separately okay so that's what we
found we found that the comte general
type that is related to prefer macaque
function predicted participants working
memory capacity parameter and that the
gpo sick gene predicted participants
reinforcement learning learning rate
individual differences and and crucially
that the reverse was not true so these
are the only two things that came okay
so this supports our conclusion that
that essentially we the to algorithmic
contributions to behavior that we've
identify kind of map onto what we know
of the brain so I've identified
something that is like working memory
contributing to reinforcement learning
parameterize by capacity here and that
relates to personal function and and I
can the learning rate I identify also in
in this in this behavior relates to to
stride or function here okay so that's
the first part of my talk while sure
that learning is a mixture of multiple
neurocognitive processes i implement
different computational trade-offs and
rely on different neural mechanisms it's
very important that even though this
task is so simple and
simplistic that you could but it seems
like you really don't need to to invoke
anything complicated to solve it we
still can find evidence of the fact that
humans use more than one system at the
same time and so it is likely to be even
more true and more interesting and
complex behavior ok and and I and I like
to show why it's important for example
in understanding this function and this
function is just an extreme case of
individual differences ok so it's also
interesting important as a way to show
how we can account for different how
different people learn ok so working
memory is very well documented to be
impaired in in in patients who have
schizophrenia and it's been learned to
prefer tall cortex function but in as
for learning the literature has always
been fairly ambiguous some some people
found that there was a learning
impairment in people with schizophrenia
and some found that there wasn't and
even in this you know same paper for
example there's Walton gold paper that's
just reversal running experiments you
had the purchased the patient's here in
black perform worse at the reversal part
of them over tasks and patient controls
but but the original learning was
exactly the same way ok so my idea here
was that well maybe the there is this
ambiguity in the literature simply
because because people use different
tasks and they tasks and then they rely
on different systems differently and so
if only one over two systems is impaired
than you would get ambiguous results ok
so that's why we tested participants on
this on this same protocol that I showed
you we replicated our previous results
or the healthy controls here and and
then we looked at the patients and here
you can see a number of things already
fairly clearly warned is the fact that
patients behavior is very lawful they're
learning at all set sizes so they're
perfectly able to learn
second they're learning worse than
controls at all set sizes they're
actually below controls but third is
that they also have a set size effect
okay so it seem like they're also using
a mixture offer enforcement learning and
working memory you can summarize their
behavior here not in a learning curve
but just that the overall performance
per set size and you see that there were
sanitation significantly but it's very
hard to tell just from looking at the
behavior this way what what the
impairment is okay so as a
counterfactual we say well let's take
the usual approach which is to assume
that there's just a single learning
mechanism for example reinforcement
learning and see what we would conclude
in this case okay so just assumption
there is an impairment here in the
behavior so presumably there should be
an impairment in the underlying neural
structures so if we fit them all a model
that just has reinforcement learning
mechanisms but for example one learning
rate per set size what do we get well if
we look at sit size 2 we find a
significant difference in the learning
rate for controls and patience and then
if we look at higher synthesis we find
significantly lower learning rate for
the patients compared to the controls
okay so if we had done only this
experiment we had said that the patients
were not impaired if we had done only
this one we would have said that there
were in brain okay so that's not
satisfying instead we're going to take
back or or our previous thinking that
there's a couple contributors here to to
behavior and say that if the behavior is
impaired then it's likely it could be
due to prefrontal cortex impairments
which should then be reflected in this
capacity parameter that captures the
working memory aspect of learning or in
the learning rate here if it's if the
impairment underlying impairment is from
straddle function for example okay so we
looked at that we fit again in patients
behavior with the computational model of
and individual parameters for example
working memory capacity and we found
significantly lower capacity for
patients compared to control okay so
that's confirming that learning is
impaired at least partly due to working
memory impairments in patients okay but
then we can ask are the deficits also
due to reinforcement learning
impairments and we can look at that by
looking at the reinforcement learning
learning rate parameter alpha here and
here we find absolutely no difference
between controls and patients okay
this is something we've replicated since
and actually strengthened since showing
that really the the the part that is
learning value policy through
reinforcement learning and behavior is
actually not impaired in patients it's
exactly the same it's really all the
learning impairment actually comes from
the working memory side of it okay so
that was the second part trying to show
you why it's actually important to
capture behavior accurately with the
mixture of of components in the last
part of my talk I'd really like to dive
a bit deeper into what those
computations are and whether they're
independent and I'll and I'll be looking
a bit at the brain here to try to answer
those questions
ok so so far we've made this surgeon
we've said we have a reinforcement
learning system it's essentially using
reward prediction errors to estimate the
value of stimulus and action there we
have a working memory system that's just
storing a stimulus action outcomes
associations and forgetting a bit and
during learning our choices are a
mixture of those two components and and
this is the only interaction between
them so they're they're interacting at
the level of choice but otherwise their
computations are completely independent
ok well I'm going to try to show today
is that maybe there are more
interactions between those two system
maybe those computations are not
actually isolating the brain ok so to do
this we did an EEG experiment so for
those of you who don't know eg measures
electrical activity on the scalp
resulting from your activity and so we
wanted to ask whether we could identify
the sociable working memory
reinforcement learning components and
interactions between them okay so the
behavior again we placated what we found
before and then we can look just at the
electrical signal at the time where you
see a stimulus and then plot this and
you get you get what we call an event
related potential ERP that looks like
this and we can separate it / as a
function of set size here and what you
see here is that you have a massive
effect of that size so this is goodbye
it's not satisfying because that size is
correlated with all kinds of things in
this experiment so we have to get a bit
more precise to understand anything okay
so to do that we simple we simply do a
trial by trial analysis so here this is
the average over all trials of the
activity in a front electrode here this
is just the activity at all trials
color-coded as a function of stimulus so
you see that it's noisy signal but it's
it's still not that noisy right you can
see the bump here fairly well and so
that's really enough signal-to-noise
ratio to be able to try to my tribal
trial independent information so what
we're going to try to do is simply say
well we have behaviorally our experiment
we know some things are related to
reinforcement learning so for example we
can extract the Q value or the reward
prediction error of the model and some
are related to working memory so for
example the set size of a delay and we
can try to put them both and other
variables as regressors and then just to
explain the activity to given time point
of a given electron as a multiple
regression where those predictors okay
and then we do what people do all the
time in fMRI which is analyze those wait
across subjects and then try to see
which areas of the signal relates to two
different signals in interesting ways
okay so I'm not going to go in detail
there the only thing that's interesting
to see is that first there's massive
signal that we can extract here and
second that we
early on in the trial for every mere
seconds we see very strong markers of
reinforcement learning that's the cue
alien signal here
and and a bit later on in the sea in the
signal at 560 milliseconds we see strong
markers of working memory okay so that
was the goal we've identified two
separable markers of Errol and working
memory and they're dynamically different
and they match what we would expect are
always faster than working memory okay
and we can visualize this I'm going to
skip this okay we can do the same the
type of feedback and find a markers or
through our prediction errors in the
brain here and now we can start asking
the interaction question so the idea is
that if I have a reinforcement learning
signal in the brain a reward prediction
error and if are always independent of
working memory then the reward
prediction error signal in the brain
should not be related to said size I
don't write only working memory should
care about that test instead this is
what we find we find that as a function
of set size this reward prediction error
signal increases essentially it seems
like we have stronger representation of
reward prediction error in higher set
sizes in higher load and that's true for
the reward prediction error and it's
also true for the stimulus at the time
of a similar to the value of the
stimulus where we're seeing right now
and this is in eg we saw the same thing
in in the striatum with fMRI the same
interaction between set size and and
reward prediction error signal okay so
that's interesting because it tells us
that the neural signals including remote
prediction errors everyone expectations
are sensitive to this working memory
function and this should maybe ring a
bell from Matt's talk about the brahmin
matching study so this indicates
possible interaction between
reinforcement learning and working
memory processes and essentially what
it's showing is that we seem to have a
blunted reinforcement learning process
and the low set sizes and remember those
studies are the easy ones to one which
is
a bit surprising right so it indicates
that this interaction here between the
two systems exists and so we wanted to
test what form this interaction took and
we had a couple hypotheses one of them
could simply be that well in low set
sizes working memory is doing a fine job
it's it's within its load so it's just
able to learn no need for error so maybe
in the situation we could have something
like that where working memory sighs hey
I'm fine we don't need you try them just
don't do don't do anything okay so
that's an something like a competition
saying like when one system is working
well it's going to inhibit the other the
other hypothesis that's closer to what
man has been talking about is that well
maybe maybe instead of cooperating in a
sense and maybe working memories
information can be passed down to
reinforcement learning in such a sense
that in such a way that it will
contribute to its computations and so
the idea here is that maybe working
memory if you're remembering to pick to
press this finger for the pumpkin you
should also be expecting to get reward
in that case and so you could be feeding
this expectation of value to the
reinforcement learning system here when
it's computing its reward prediction err
so instead of it being closed loop it
would become an open loop okay so
there's our two hypotheses they make
some similar prediction and some
distinguishable predictions so if I
simulate those two models here is what
I'm plotting the estimated value of our
choice and you see that in this case
it's just telling me this competition
accounts say is that learning is going
to be slower for the arel system in low
set sizes when working memory is done
well and the reward prediction error is
also going to decrease slower just
because our system is inhibited so it's
not learning okay the cooperation
account also predicts that the learning
is going to be lower smaller slower for
error loss in sizes but for a different
reason
here the idea is that because what you
memory learns very fast what to expect
and because it feeds it to the reward
prediction error no the reward
prediction error in this case is going
to drop down very fast okay
it's going to drop down faster than it
should and that's why the system is
going to learn slower okay so there are
two competing predictions so I went into
the eg and I identify those markers try
Batra markers of of reinforcement
learning and looked at it in in those
learning curve ways okay so this is the
activity the reinforcement learning
areas of the signal and you see that in
increases faster for higher set sizes
than followers in sizes as predicted by
both models that's supporting the fact
that there is an interaction but then
when I look at the word prediction error
at the time of feedback you see that
it's this activity in the brain
decreases much faster for the low set
sizes okay and that's what was predicted
by the co-operative account not by the
competitive account okay so it seems to
show that working memory is messing with
the computations of RL by fitting it its
value expectations okay we actually
looked at this a bit more precisely
trial by trial we said well it was true
trial by trial that's true and I should
see in a trial and specifically in
trials where the brain seems to show
that participants are you using working
memory
I should see this in effect I should see
this effect in the at the time of reward
in the in the reward prediction error
representation in the brain okay and so
that's what we found we found that how
much the brain represented around Q
values at the time of stimulus predicted
negatively how much feedback reward
prediction error we found and that's
normal due to the formula for our
prediction reward minus expected value
but then the working memory use also
predicted very strongly
the feedback signal on the brain okay so
this supports this working memory
contribution hypothesis okay and it
makes another very interesting
behavioral prediction which is that
essentially the rear the reinforcement
learning system is being subdued when in
low set sizes when watch memory is going
well so you're you're lying something
very easily you're using your working
memory it's like well this is super easy
and but what that means is that in the
background the Aral system is not doing
its job and so what this is saying is
that if you've learned something very
easily with working memory you should be
much worse later on at remembering it so
in the end it's making the prediction
that your performance during learning
process i6 is going to be worse than
it's at sy3 and that's because you're
using working memory here but then if I
test you on it later after after after a
break then all of a sudden you should be
better at what you've learned you know
in a more difficult way which is
counterintuitive okay so we tested that
in participants they show the usual
learning face effect of working memory
here so better learning inside science
it's Isaac's but then when we tested
them later they were actually better
performing they were able to remember
much better which actions to pick when
they had learnt with five other things
than with two other things okay this is
again a replicating effect so to
summarize I've tried to show that
working memory interferes in the
reinforcement learning computations of
value and so that what is learned faster
is actually learnt worse in the end okay
and even though I call this interaction
cooperative and so this opens very
interesting questions for the future
because it's saying well it seems
cooperative and in a sense but in this
case it's it's is making performance
worse in the future so it's undermining
one of the usefulness of reinforcement
learning so something that we want to
understand later
is why is this happening in the brain
why if we have those two systems that
are at different sides of trade off
they're working together during learning
that makes sense because in that sense
you can make good use of where that good
each of them is separately good but now
with this interaction was saying well
they're actually interfering with this
ability to move at different sides of
the trade off so why is this why is this
potentially normative is something that
we're trying to figure out now hey I
like to acknowledge my colleagues in
here and so we actually tested yes
that's something to be tested but so one
question for example we could ask there
is
okay so that's that's the simpler
question and and the the caveat I ain't
tell in my tasks and my talk is that
those patients are medicated and I have
not tested them on Medicaid so what I
can say is that I have not found
evidence for for reinforcement learning
dysfunction in patients with
schizophrenia who are medicated and
those medications are effectively
dopaminergic system so it's entirely
yeah it's classic antipsychotics yeah
and so so it's entirely possible then
non-medicated patients there will be
something we have a little bit of
evidence against that because we found
no drug dependent drug doses dependent
effect in the behavior that is related
to era but that's that's what we have so
far hopefully at some point we can test
patients who are on Medicaid in and get
a better sense for your first question
so so working so what you're saying is
that we could have they could have
multiple parts of prefrontal cortex that
one of them could contribute to working
memory just holding in my action to pick
forgiving stimulus another one could be
contributing to them to the value
expectation and then we do know about FC
projects to the dopaminergic areas so
that's totally possible something we
tried in this task is say here I have
this mixture parameter here that tells
me how much working memory is
contributing to choice so that's telling
me how much working memory in the sense
of the policy of working memory is
contributing to choice and I have this
parameter here was telling me how much
is working memory contributing to the
interference to to the expectation of
reward in in the computation of error
here and when I sent them along I found
that if I let those two be independent
it wasn't worth the added complexity so
it seemed and and if I in a fraidy they
were very collated with each other
really the the best-fitting morale was
one where those two parameters were the
same okay so that's a very indirect in a
sense but in direct evidence that there
is at least a link between those two
systems and that's something that we
want to try to test in in animal
behavior that's something that would be
fairly hard to death in humans so I have
a collaboration right now I'm trying to
this may be now a new way of testing
with your method know some movie
theories right because we understand
correctly he had assigned wishes tasks
to the working memory because this is no
network dynamics right so I think
there's a number of links that haven't
made directly but one of them Matt
pointed out that for clarity you know
they turn off the reinforcement learning
learning rate right when they test and
so that way they get only the inner loop
dynamics I guess and and that's for
simplicity right is to convince people
that those dynamics are sufficient to do
reinforcement learning but I I presume I
could just turn back on their
reinforcement learning learning rate and
that way I have both you know in my
sense that we mean essentially that they
killed around here right and they kept
only working memory okay and so I proved
they could turn back on arrow and see
how that modifies the network's behavior
and so how it behaves in this case the
second link is I think the Bromberg
matching study with this interaction
being curious is essentially also saying
like confirming you know like from
another angle what you guys found is
that where we're finding a game that
this
when you when you're like preferable
contacts being involved in this
computation officer and the
reinforcement learning dopamine signals
might become more interesting and more
you know let small free in in a sense
and more and more more using more
external or cognitive information into
them essentially no shy answer your
question though one thing that we got
into in the discussion section of the
people are expressive after that I was
talking about is there's nothing in our
theory that is meant to contradict yeah
yeah there may also be sort of more
traditional model 3rl going on on the
side which you would get if the alert
you imagine there's a spectrum of
learning rates at synapses across some
dimension of scribal anatomy so so in
that sense there's also kind of like
degree freedom in our work that that you
know the lines with degrees of freedom
here the interesting to consider I
actually wanted to ask you two different
questions just from like a purely
putting off my cognitive psychologist
how to secure the finding that people
remember the high load stuff better than
the low lows really provocative I wonder
though like whether there there's a
compound and that you might have
considered so you know there's this very
well-established idea in cognitive
psychology about death depth of depth of
the study like the the harder you think
about something when you're learning it
and the more kind of lincoln semantic
linkages you form the more you're gonna
remember it later and my my guests
having done a lot of you know studies
that are kind of like this with human
participants is that when things get
challenging people come up with all
sorts of heuristics and verbal
strategies and so i wonder like when you
talk to your to your participants today
did they say oh you remember those hard
ones because i have made up a little
narrative about how you know the picture
of the treaty went with the picture of
the apple and
you roll that out I can truly out
completely I don't really want to roll
it out completely because I think that's
actually probably very related to is
finding but I can tell you is that
people think they're better because you
so that's that's to actually store
answers to this one of them is the first
answer is that I'm relying on on past
literature that has you know taking this
kind of tasks and again and again and
again links to reinforcement learning
neural system you know like dopamine has
an effect and that if you give
dopaminergic drugs it modifies learning
etc so so that's that that's one angle
in which I'm saying like I think it's
people are treating this like a
reinforcement learning algorithm because
it's um tasks because lots of past
research has shown this the other
question is I agree with you it could be
seen as a non you know it's essentially
statistical learning tasks of some kind
and but then the question is what counts
as reward and do things you know for
example if I had known list
a squid if I had told people you know I
given them a random non non valuable
word until them now this is your goal
and something else no this is not your
goal like you know instead of correct
and incorrect for example you know white
board and black board for example and if
I had told them that and if they had
been learning with this weather I would
have seen similar effects and that's the
question of whether people decide to
attribute reward value to things based
on what the goal of a task is and that's
something that there hasn't been that
much work on but that there is fairly
good evidence that people actually
create their own reward functions like
this in a way that ends up calling on
the dopaminergic system okay so it goes
in both ways essentially there that
could absolutely be a completely non
reinforcement learning way to solve this
task but for all non obviously
reinforcement learning tasks out there
it's also very possible that people just
create their own reward functions and
still treat it like a reinforcement
learning task
[Applause]